hey guys thanks so much for joining us
for this video today just a reminder
we're hosting Jubilee prom on April 17
yeah April 17th and if you're asking
someone out on a date to prom then don't
forget to use hashtag Jubilee prom or
hashtag promposal and tag us at Jubilee
media and don't forget to follow us on
Instagram that's where we're posting a
ton of information and updates for the
prom so go ahead and give us all there
and please stay tuned to the end of the
episode because we have a big challenge
for you alright guys enjoy the episode I
fell in love with one of my closest
friends he told me that even though we
weren't right for each other we'd still
be friends and hang out and talk now I
wants nothing to do with me and it
annoys me at all cost I feel absolutely
empty
[Music]
my crush stopped being friends with me
because he didn't want to be in a
relationship with me so I started
texting him off a fake number with a
different name I text him every now and
then but he's never realized it's me I
had a crush of my friend borderline
being in love with her and so when she
left the room one time I unmatched her
with someone on tinder so they just went
through her phone dang that's kind of
like holding her back too isn't it like
if you really loved her then
wouldn't you just let her be with
whoever she wants to be with I am in a
committed relationship yet I have a
crush on another man I feel guilty
confused and shameful the relationship I
have with my boyfriend is magical and I
never expected something like this to
happen to me
I was dating somebody for like six
months towards the end of it I like fell
in love with one of my best friends and
it was just one of the most difficult
things I'd personally experienced just
emotionally and like morally you know I
think it's unfair to blame yourself for
that you can't control your emotions you
can't choose who you like and you don't
like that's not it's not anybody's fault
I fell in love with one of my closest
friends he told me that even though we
weren't right for each other we'd still
be friends and hang out and talk now I
wants nothing to do with me and it
annoys me at all cost I feel absolutely
empty I did go through this situation
not that long ago I did feel really sad
and like felt like what was wrong with
me or like why does he not want to
reciprocate these feelings I wanted
answers that he wasn't willing to give
me and so I just had to come to the
realization that some things are just
better left unsaid and that if I was
meant to know I would have known
it was hard to come to that conclusion
because I'm the type of person that
loves closure but it's not guaranteed
for everyone so I came out as a lesbian
when I was around 14 and my best friend
was my first girl crush I wanted to
confess but she is homophobic so I knew
I could never tell her her comments on
homosexual people got so bad that I
started cutting myself I myself in the
lesbian I realize around that same time
like 14 that I was I had never really
told anyone about it because I was
scared of like peoples like perceptions
I think you need to tell her because if
she has this like close-minded view of
the world it's not gonna help her grow
either and it's cheesy as it sounds like
it's gonna get better and who you are as
a person like that's who you should love
I'm in love with my best friend I left
our mutual workplace on a city a few
months ago I told everyone I was excited
for a new opportunity but I actually
left because it's too hard to be just
friends with him and work together every
day I've regretted leaving and not
speaking my truth every day since now
I'll never know what could have been I
fell for a guy for two years we became
close friends I never told him how I
felt out of fear of ruining a friendship
he recently moved back home from Texas
not even knowing that I would go with
him if only he asked me to I think about
it every day he was the one that got
away I can understand being afraid being
vulnerable about your feelings is always
like terrifying instead of viewing it is
like scary just think about like how
brave that is to talk about how you feel
and admit to someone how you feel I
think there's actually like a lot more
strength and bravery in that than like
hiding it forever
there was a guy who worked with and we
spent the summer going out for drinks
hanging out and sleeping together
I ended up falling in love with him but
didn't tell him when I went to work in a
different state for half a year he
ghosted me right after I left I still
think about him to this day
and wonder what I did wrong well I can
say if Solan is to ghosts another person
to have that amount of disregard for
another person that's more reflection of
them than you too many times in romantic
encounters people look inward when
there's wrongdoing I didn't attribute
good things to their partner if someone
goes to you
that's soand that's honestly not worth
any more of your energy never had a
significant other asked nor have I been
taken on a date I used to make me feel
as though I have something wrong with me
I'm too ugly too fat or just not enough
he caused me to think I had no right to
have a choice or a boundaries I'm sorry
that you feel that way but that's not
true you are good enough now just
because you've never been asked on a
date welcome to my life I've never been
asked on a date either but I don't think
that I'm not good enough I think that
everybody is different and everybody
expects something different but you are
good enough
hey guys thanks so much for checking out
that episode I really enjoyed getting to
be a part of it I hope you guys enjoyed
it too yeah banya was super awesome to
see you in the episode reading secrets
from people who are just so brave to put
themselves out there and talking about
bravery we're coming up with a series
called the leap hashtag the leap
challenge we want to challenge you to
reconnect and reach out to maybe a
family member you had a falling-out with
an old friend you maybe have to ask
forgiveness or even call your parents to
say as simple I love you so if you're
interested in taking the leap challenge
go to the link in our description fill
out the form below and maybe yours is a
story that will be towing and some of
these upcoming episodes yep thanks for
watching and see you guys next time bye
guys bye guys be safe
[Music]